new in theaters this weekend Maleficent
mistress of evil and Zombieland double
tap what will you see this is your
weekend ticket there ask me to marry him
no I wasn't really asking nor was I love
doesn't always end well beasty
trust me let us prove you wrong you have
done an admirable job going against your
own nature to raise this child but now
she will finally get the love of a real
mother tonight I consider Aurora
my
what have you done we go home
Aurora
Angelina Jolie returns as Maleficent
this weekend and Maleficent mistress of
evil things have been at peace for five
years between the fairies in the human
since the first film but when a new
queen played by Michelle Pfeiffer
threatens to cause a rift between the
two races Aurora and Maleficent are
faced with deciding on their future
allegiances this movies for you if
you're a fan of Disney's live-action
offerings you're a fan of the first
Maleficent or if you consider yourself a
Sleeping Beauty
welcome to zombie land life is about
more than just survival we were a family
dysfunctional sure but what family isn't
[Music]
I really like for you to stop calling me
though I do you know and I would like I
don't give a [ __ ] what you it felt so
good to be on the move again
oh my god I'm so sorry hi I'm Candace
this is Tallahassee hey poplar this your
dad
Oh whoopsie I forgot this he thought
wrong Oh so she knows the rules I told
her just a few of him
7300 and are there more here cute like
it 10 years after the original came out
the sequel Zombieland double tap comes
out this weekend the film also takes
place 10 years later as the original for
misfits romp around the apocalypse meet
new survivors new forms of zombies and
new ways to kill said zombies I mean you
really shouldn't need more but here bill
murray returns okay that should be
enough this movies for you if you love
to the first movie you're looking for a
fun action comedy this weekend or if you
only watch a movie every 10 years that's
pretty convenient and weird you're weird
that is your weekend ticket what will
you see and check back next week to find
out when you die wow I sounded way too
cheery